[Musique]
la passion de léandre c'est le violent
il en joue depuis qu'il a 3 ans et demi
et pratique deux heures par jour
je suis très concentré sur qu'est-ce que
je joue que là j'oublie tous les
soutiens
en décembre 2018 léandre et sa famille
ont reçu une terrible nouvelle il y
avait du mal à la tête un petit peu dosé
puis on pensait pas que ça grands
chevaux ses mille et à les faire passer
une mort à l'hôpital et puis mais c'est
là qu'ils ont vu une tumeur dans son
cerveau d'un grosseur d'une petite
clémentine même durant ces traitements
léandre continuer à jouer avec la même
passion c'était vraiment difficile la
chimio puis il est violent mais mehdi
stade de ces choses
la fondation rêves d'enfants lui offert
de réaliser un rêve
il aurait pu demander un voyage à disney
ou nouvelle console mais non voulait un
cours avec un team 20 go offre justement
via le net préféré ajouter aussi si
c'est possible
à monaco où la bête là il aime tellement
qu'il ait mis son chef wendi en son
honneur
kfw d'obliger la classe de maître lieu
virtuellement via la plateforme web de
van der hoff mais des changes du tout
aussi passionnant j'aime beaucoup
comment expliquer des choses comme c'est
des choses qui savait déjà mais a
expliqué dans une façon que j'ai
vraiment compris qu est ce qu on voulait
des herbes et hommes oui aussi présent
pris deux fois un bon moment pour le
maestro aussi tendre et grasse ont très
musical très amusant j'ai admiré son
énergie c'est celle plus important
énergie et
maurer pour musées et les progrès ont
été immédiats selon son accompagnatrice
s'approchait plus des plus grands et ça
ce n'est plus détendu maxime van der
hoff est convaincu du pouvoir guérisseur
de la musique dont nos deux matchs où
les 'tendre' va mieux et les médecins
continuent de suivre l'évolution de sa
condition avec attention tous souhaite
de tout coeur que les rendre plus
continuer longtemps à répondre le
bonheur avec la musique ici nabi
alexandre charti radio canada montréal
[Musique]